make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so a lot of people have been asking
for this and in reality I guess it
really was only a matter of time before
we did it too powerful for Marvel movies
oblivion now here's the crazy thing
about it here's here's here's the thing
about oblivion people really seem to
make the concept of his character far
more complicated than it needs to be
right so I want to talk about a handful
of things here I want to talk about what
are called abstract realms right like
cosmic ron's cosmic entities so one of
the things that was established in the
early 90s and the quasar comics is that
when when an event happens like Infinity
Gauntlet like the Infinity Gauntlet
story or the events of like Hickman's
Avengers the New Avengers or whatever
whenever any event happens and the
cosmic entities outside of the
Celestials and Galactus appear to people
they're basically borrowed bodies but
cosmic entities are in of themselves
abstract concepts me they don't actually
have a physical form so it's it's like a
thought in your head right like if I say
think of what the weather was today that
concept does it have a physical form
right it's not like it comes out of your
brain and then talks to you but the
question is what if it did the way that
works in Marvel Comics is through
something called the dimension of
manifestations and that was established
back in the old quasar comics when Gregg
Coppola was drawing it and so on and so
forth but the idea is that you have
what's called anthropomorphic and so
whenever any event takes place that
requires cosmic entities to appear to
somebody then basically their non
existing forms travel directly to to the
Domitian of manifestations and then they
in turn get a physical form and then
they leave the division of
manifestations and then they show up in
the main Marvel Universe or something
like that now that's the way it was for
years and years and years and years and
then Avengers Academy number seven
happen and the way that's the reason why
that matters is because in that story
there was a fight between ant-man Hank
Pym and crusher creel there comes a
point when ant-man grows astronomically
large and takes a crusher creel with him
and basically travels to a places called
over space and what this is is basically
the kind of the establishment of the
idea that the cosmic entities actually
do have physical forms and they reside
inside that over space it's basically
where they come from they all hang out
there I don't know play video games they
play Mario Party all day long until
something happens that needs our
attention who knows what they do but
they basically all just kind of hang out
there and then up here whenever they
need to now when it comes to the over
space that is something that's like
outside the multiverse right so you have
like you know this this huge multi
space and then you have the over space
outside the multiverse which is where
the Living Tribunal resides every single
universe has its own over space which is
where the universe's individual cosmic
entity resides right so like inside the
over space for the main model universe
is eternity and infinity and mistress
death and those characters so again it's
it's kind of strange but then you have
what's called the outer void now the
outer void is more or less the same
thing is like over space but it only has
one occupant and that one occupant is
oblivion and the way this works is that
oblivion is the representation of the
multiverses destruction essentially like
this space between the multiverses
destruction and recreation right so like
say for example that the multiverse is
destroyed like it was during the events
of seeker Wars you know I'm sorry that's
of Hickman's Avengers of New Avengers
and say it takes like 20 minutes for the
multiverse to come back that 20 minute
gap is what oblivion represents the
non-existence of anything the way that
that oblivion states that in Marvel
Comics is that all existence came from
him and all existence will return to him
right now the issue with this is that
it's stated by oblivion it's not like
another source so it's basically
oblivion kind of saying hey I am the
origin of all things you have to believe
me that's basically what it comes down
to and so because of that you can't
really take it as a credible source and
so we can kind of go with it because
that's what they kind of say I mean
until something else comes along that
kind of contradicts that we just sort of
have to roll with it but people always
kind of relate oblivion to like mistress
death
how does oblivion relate to mistress
death okay the notion behind this is
that mistress death while she is kind of
listed as like a sister of sorts or like
really I guess during a discussion with
herself and Galactus she was kind of
listed like she kind of say to herself
to be like a sister to oblivion she's
not she's more like a daughter and the
reason why is because oblivion again as
the representation of the time it takes
between the multiverses destruction and
its recreation he's a multiversal being
right like he's like The Living Tribunal
he's a multiversal concept there's only
one of him throughout the entire
multiverse but every single universe has
its own version of mistress death and so
the question becomes if every universe
has its own version of mistress death is
there a multiversal version of mistress
death yes that's oblivion that's the
nature of it that all the versions of
death as they exists in Marvel Comics
he'll directly from oblivion and the
reason why is is is for most for the
most part it's a new concept the reason
why it's a new is because back in the
day it was kind of this this notion that
like oblivion could only really
we have some measure of impact on those
individuals who died due to being wiped
from existence basically but it was
later expanded and kinda brought him
that oblivion has domain over all
individuals who died all beings who died
and so because of this it's really
possible for oblivion to kind of like
take a person who died and then bring
them to his realm if he chose to but
mistress death also has her own
afterlife so again it gets kind of hairy
and it gets kind of crazy the long and
short behind this is that oblivion is a
multiversal concept and that I would go
as far as to say that like every version
of mistress death that exists throughout
the throughout the multiverse is a
version of him it's basically like a
kind of a portion of himself
split across the various universes now
why does this makeup live Ian too
powerful for the Marvel movies well
because oblivion is insane I mean it's
basically saying like what if God was
evil there was a story that mama comics
wrote called a chaos war and this was
basically like the introduction of a
monster my Kobashi right like this guy
went on a warpath across like the the
universe right like hilling aunt like
like the Olympians were basically pushed
to like the near brink of extinction
like almost every single god that the
chaos king fought he killed it was
insane how powerful he was he had like
this astronomical army of forces and so
on and so forth but despite the fact
that the godly pantheon of the Marvel
Universe was almost pushed to the total
brink of extinction like chaos King
himself by the story that we saw is
basically an aspect of oblivion and
possesses like a fraction of oblivion
power and so if someone with a fraction
of Oblivion's power was able to almost
lay waste in its entirety the entire
pantheon of gods and cosmic entities as
they exist in Marvel Comics in a
singular universe what hope does anybody
have against him this isn't like the
molecule man Owen Reese right where's a
guy who's not really evil and he's
easily manipulated and has no real
confidence in himself it's not someone
like Matt Jim Jasper's who requires a
reality to warp him that if he's taken
to a space where there is no universe
it's just a giant white void he's
basically human and could be shot with a
bullet and killed you're talking about
this omniverse whole omnipresent almost
omnipotent near to sneer indestructible
being that depending on how you look at
it could be considered an equal to the
Living Tribunal and second to the one
above all outside of the be honours and
so on it's nothing we could really
defeat but you take a character like
that and you throw them into the MCU and
no one would really be able to stand
against him as he exists in the current
form the only the only way you could
really destroy someone like oblivion is
if you had a prereq on molecule man
basically the molecule
when he was at his absolute peak in
power when he was really as powerful as
he'd ever been you would have to have to
have somebody like the beyonders who
were wiping out all the cosmic entities
across the cosmos protégé could
definitely do it
the original Doctor Strange who had no
limit to his power he was infinitely
powerful you could count six people
maybe who would stand a chance against
that but none of them exists in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's weird
that people ask this because it's like
what would happen if a being so
astronomically powerful that some of
those powerful beings in Marvel Comics
could have no conceivable hope of
defeating him like what would happen if
he showed up in the MCU like it's it's
kind of crazy I mean like okay so people
so somebody like the fulcrum could
probably defeat him but even then like
the fulcrum is a universal entity and in
some argue it's an aspect to the one
above all until it's explicitly stated
there's no reason to believe that it is
it's weird it's it's just it's weird and
funky and crazy and it's an
astronomically powerful being I mean I
don't really know how you make a case
where the heroes could win I don't
really know it's not like you get a
world break or Hulk right like well we
get world record called roaring Hulk or
like rune King Thor no not a chance like
I mean no no no one you mentioned could
do it like outside of like five or six
people no one you could think of could
destroy oblivion because he's just so
astronomically powerful it's crazy I
don't know how to stress this I don't
know how else to this point it's just
too astronomically powerful for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's just not
it's never gonna work I mean like I said
he's a multiversal being if it was
Universal well then just get the
Infinity Gauntlet you're done I mean
that that's that's all it would take
right if it's like too powerful from
Marvel movies eternity no he's not
either just get the Infinity Gauntlet in
the eternities defeated we've seen that
play out with a multiversal beam that's
really what shifts things in Marvel
Comics when you leave the realm of a
being that's powerful throughout the
entire universe and then you expand that
into a being who's like multiversal
powerful then you're talking about a
crazy level you're talking about almost
unbeatable I mean Jim Jasper's might be
able to do it with the Jaspers warped
but the problem is the Jaspers warp
takes time well the time Jim Jasper's
thought about the idea of initiating the
Jaspers war he be wiped out of existence
by oblivion and that was just that that
would be it so if there are other
dimensional beings that might be able to
do it but they're only Universal like
your mom was really powerful but he's
really powerful on a universal level
he's not multiversal right likes in Iraq
is not multiversal he's Universal but
yeah I don't know it's it's it would be
nuts they'd be interesting if he kind of
curious but hey guys
being down in the description or down in
the comment section about what you guys
think because again it's a weird kind of
choice to go with I mean it's an
astronomically powerful multiversal
being whose could only be defeated about
like maybe five people you know I mean
the cut other cosmic entities you know
that are equivalent to him could but
like aside from that probably not that's
one of the weird things because like I
was over was it somebody directed me to
the to the Marvel wiki on oblivion and
it was like he can be defeated by like
his brothers and sisters like eternity
and infinity and mistress death and is
like no he can't either because like
there are only Universal they're not
multiversal being so don't believe
everything you read on Marvel wiki's
guys always go with the comic book
source but with that being said we're
gonna go and bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the robb core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]